- All she's got
(intense music)
is me. (gun cocking)
She's comin' home
(explosion)
He started this.
(intense music and guns shooting)
I'll end it.
I'm gonna tear you apart.
- First Rambo was 1982, 37 years ago,
so if I had said to you,
if somebody had said to you in 1982,
it's gonna be one of the
longest running franchises
in history, what would
your reaction have been?
- Impossible because no one
even wanted the first one.
I was the eleventh choice,
and I basically had to do a song and dance
to get a distributor.
So, it was always a very remote character,
an isolated character,
kinda like what he was, so
the fact that we're here today,
it's a modern miracle,
a "cinematic" miracle.
- Did anybody ever tell you,
'cause you said so many
actors turned down the role,
has anybody ever come to you,
there's always like the famous,
"I wish I hadn't turned that down."
Who came to you and said I
wish I never turned down Rambo?
- Well, it was actually the director.
Everyone else is kinda like,
actors would go "I didn't want it anyway,"
(Interviewer laughing)
"Or I would have done it better."
Actually one actor came up to me.
I think it was John Savage
or someone like that,
or the fella from Midnight Ride, he goes,
"I would have played it naked."
- Oh my gosh.
- Really?
- That would have been a
different type of film.
- That's the story that I heard,
that he wanted to play it,
which is not weird--
- It's not a terrible idea.
- No no seriously. (chuckling)
Those branches are bad
if you know what I mean.
The thing is, the character
was so savage in the beginning
that he was naked.
- So it makes sense.
- Oh yeah, it wasn't like
I was making fun of him.
He was as primitive and feral as you get,
and that's why he had to be killed.
- Speaking of savage, you put
on your Instagram recently
John's man cave 'cause you have quite
an elaborate man cave in this film,
I know you live with a lot of women.
Do you have a man cave?
And where do you go when
you need to have that time?
- Well, my man cave has been invaded
by female bear caves.
So, I thought I had one so
now all I have is my office,
which is kinda like the ego room.
'cause every now and
then, so much memorabilia
and I put it around the house.
She goes, "Everything's about you!"
I go, "So?"
(Interviewer laughs)
- I think your daughter said that.
- Yeah. So everything's
been shoved in my office,
so you go in there and it's actually
overload and bobble heads.
- The Oscars are there.
- Everything is there so.
- Everything?
Everything.
- That's the place you go.
When you're talking about
nostalgia and everything
that's in your office,
'cause I think you posted
something recently too,
it was your greatest hits.
But it was kind of a spoof.
What is your greatest hit?
What do you think your greatest hit is?
Film-wise, a moment, a scene, a character?
- Oh boy, some of them are losers.
Like F.I.S.T. I thought
was a really good film.
I thought that Nighthawks is great movie.
And eventually I think
they're going to make it
now as a series.
That bothered me.
I thought Cop Land.
- Cop Land was wonderful.
- It should have deserved better fate.
They released it during the summer
and I thought it's really
not a summer movie.
But yeah, yeah.
And I love working with Kurt Russel,
that was the favorite.
- Well, I was gonna ask you
because you've now brought us
Rambo back after almost,
a little over 10 years.
You gave us Rocky recently.
Congratulations on all
your awards with Creed.
Is there another character
that you would like to bring back?
I vote for either Over The Top,
Tango & Cash,
- Lincoln Hawk, yeah.
- I loved that movie.
Is there a character
you'd like to bring back?
- Well, if you're gonna do it,
I'm talking with Robert
Rodriguez right now,
I hope he doesn't mind,
about Cobra, which looks like
that can happen as a series.
Basically his baby now.
I would do Tango & Cash in a second
because I know with Kurt it's not about
really "a caper," it's
just us doing that thing.
And he goes, "I dunno Sly.
We're looking at, there
we are in our prime,
and now we're like in our
un-prime and I dunno."
I said, "Kurt that's not, I'm telling you,
you got it goin on."
But he goes on, "I'll talk
to you when I get back."
- We do Guardians, and
I know James has said
he wants you back for
Guardians, like a bigger role.
Is that gonna happen or?
- Really? James is a man
of his word so if he,
whatever he wants.
I love James though if he wants to do it,
yeah it'd be great.
(brooding dramatic music)
I've lived in a world of death.
(rocking chair creaking)
I've watched people I've loved die,
some fast with a bullet,
some not enough left to bury.
- For both of you,
even though this is an action movie
and Sly is known for action movies,
for the both of you, it
was very dramatic material.
Sly was just sort of telling me
that it was one of those
movies that he's like
"How far do we go?
How far do we push things?"
And I think you really went there,
so if you could talk a
little bit about that.
- (mumbles)
- Yeah, sure, so I feel like this Rambo,
all the previous Rambo's
have been about war,
but I feel like this one
is a little more intimate
because it does touch on family.
He's never had a family before
and this is the first time
he gets to go back home
to his ranch, live a
simple life, and then boom.
I end up rebelling and going to Mexico and
the war starts again.
He has to go and protect his family.
And I do love that it sheds
light on the sex trafficking.
Although Rambo isn't all about it,
it sheds light on it
and I feel like that was
super important because it's
a big problem in America.
Everywhere actually.
- Yes and this film, the
opportunity to the audience
to see a human being, its unique.
Because it's not only an
action figure, an action icon,
the audience can see that human being with
age, with a broken soul,
and I think the audience can embrace
being the hero.
- And I think that's why
people love Sylvester Stallone is because
well one thing that was nice
about this is like you said,
you don't often see him
talking a lot in films,
and this is the most dialogue
he's ever had in a Rambo film.
And so for the two of you,
because you two had the bulk
of your scenes with him,
having that conversation,
what was the first moment like?
Was it kind of like, "Oh my
gosh. It's a legend! It's Sly."?
- Well, my first moment was,
actually an action scene
you saw the movie right?
So when he goes and
picks me up to save me,
and I was like, "Ah! Ah!"
Yeah that was my first scene.
(everyone laughing)
I was really nervous
but I was glad it was
an action scene because
I was able to see him
and just used to him and his
aura, and just how he was,
and talk to him more, because
I was really nervous at first,
I mean this is a big franchise
and he's Rocky and Rambo,
so I'm glad the action
stuff happened first
but he definitely had my back
and wanted me to do my best work
so he laid it out there
like "I'm your friend and we are good."
- My first scene was
when he is with a horse
and I said, "Oh my God,
he is not only an action
and this kind of a icon and actor,
he's a wonderful rider with a horse.
- Yeah really good rider with a horse.
- And it was a beautiful
time, obviously I was excited,
because I will acting
with Sylvester Stallone
and, for the first time, we
connect at the beginning.
It was easy and beautiful.
- Yeah, favorite movie of his?
'cause I know his daughters were asked
what their favorite and they said Creed
and I think it's funny 'cause it's
more for a younger generation.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And I'm wondering if you have a favorite?
- Cop Land.
He said that was one of
his proudest moments.
- He's fantastic in there.
- Aww. I really, really loved Rocky I.
He talks so much about it.
I mean its funny because I watched it
on the plane ride there,
when I was about to film,
- You did?
and then I brought it up to him
and he gave me so much details
about behind the scenes.
I don't know if you
remember that one scene,
where he was on the
roller rink with Adrian?
- Yeah, of course.
And he popped his finger out
and then he popped it back in,
that was actually real!
There's so many details I was like "What?"
So, I love Rocky I.
- And last question.
I know he has a man cave in this,
and you know how guys have their man cave?
So I'm gonna ask you ladies,
when you need to escape
and escape the business and that
where's your place that you go?
- Hmm. I like to,
I don't know that's kinda tough because
I have so many places, like I
live right next to the beach
so I like to go to the beach,
I like to hike a little bit.
Or I like to go to WeWork.
It's really nice place.
(Interviewer laughing)
- It's very L.A.
- (Yvette laughing) Yeah.
(translator mumbling to Adriana)
- Mountains.
I like mountains.
I love cold
because I born in a cold place.
And trees.
I love wood.
(intense trailer music and guns shooting)
- I want them to know
(music intensifies)
that death
is coming.
(intense music)
- So now we have the family all together.
Was this what it was like?
There's a lot of joking around.
Did I hear something
about a secret handshake?
- No, I was just...
- If it was like this,
Rambo would've hung himself.
(Interviewer laughing)
We get along great, but obviously
this is kind of a testament to acting
'cause you turn it on when
you have to and afterwards,
people are funny.
- This is the way it is
and usually in dramatic films,
people say it's the funniest on set.
So there's a line in the movie,
there's a time that you two
are having this conversation,
where you say, "I don't
know what I wanna do."
And you say, as John Rambo,
"I always wanted to be a soldier."
So I wanted to ask the three of you,
is this always what you wanted to do?
(translator talking to Adriana in Spanish)
- No
- Really? (laughing)
- Really.
I wanted to do a ballerina.
- Aww.
- All my life, but I cannot.
- So did I.
(everyone laughing)
- Wow.
- Yeah, you know?
Well, dancing together.
But, I never can, I never could.
And then, I had to (speaks Spanish)
- She had to take a specific
class theater or basketball.
- When I was a young girl.
- Theater or basketball?
(laughing)
- I didn't like basketball.
- I wanna come back as you.
Wow.
- And then I discovered
theater at my 16's.
And I was really happy because
I know this is my place.
- Feels right.
- I wanted to train horses.
That was it and
that's why I tried to put
it in as much as possible.
- You did!
- Yeah, I love 'em.
That was my calling. (Stallone chuckles)
And I said, "Hmm."
And I actually auditioned for a play
to get out of doing
sports, believe it or not.
And I got the part and I
said, "Huh that's not bad."
And that was the beginning.
But no it wasn't,
I'm not one of these people that wake up
at two and a half hours old
and go "I'm gonna be an actress,"
before they even learn to feed.
No.
- Wow, but you didn't want to do sports,
but you're the biggest action
hero of all time. (laughing)
Go figure!
- I actually wanted to be a veterinarian
and then an interior
designer, marine biologist,
but then I decided acting!
I at first started doing special effects
because I felt scared to be an actress.
I felt like, ah its one in a million.
and I was actually told it
was easier to win the lottery
than to be an actress, so I believed them.
But now, I'm glad I listened to myself.
- You left out astronaut too. (laughing)
- So how did the casting process,
were you a part of the casting process?
- Oh yeah, very much.
- How did how did it all come about
and how did you both find out?
- Well, of course, when she
was cast, it's no brainer.
We're lucky to get her.
- Thank you.
The young Gabrielle was hard
and there was hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of people
'cause there's an essence,
physically how does it look?
Can she play the right age?
Also, be able to really bring it out, cry
and to bring emotion.
She got it.
- Yeah, well for me I had
to go through a process,
it was three steps.
So I did the casting
director with Carla Hool
and then I met with Adrian via Skype,
and then I did an in person
test with Sylvester Stallone.
- Yeah, it was me against two other girls.
But it did feel pretty natural
for some reason I felt like,
I could tell he knew what he wanted
and I felt secure like,
"Okay lets do this."
- Well, what you just hit it on the word.
It's a natural, when actors are flowing.
That's a gift.
- But that's something
you're really well known for.
It's not always about the dialogue
its about what's behind it.
- Yeah, always.
- Even though Rambo has more dialogue
with these ladies in the
film than he's ever had.
- Than all the movies put together.
- Yeah, so talk a little bit about that.
Why now and why was that important?
- Well, actually, the
majority of the time is
I'm answering questions, basically,
from her, that's why I say,
"It's gonna be kinda
quiet when you leave."
They're like my daughters,
and there's always questions
so I don't really have anything
to say, I'm responding.
I feel that the relationship
with her grandmother and
John was a whole other thing.
She was kind of like
my mother, but not.
See what I mean?
She's like something I wish.
Maternal, you know what I mean?
Even though I'm much older
than her, I don't have that.
So it was a perfect blend.
- Thank you all so much.
And you probably got to go method
because you have so many
women around you in your life.
- Method. (laughing)
What is that?
(Fandango music)